what is going on there reject nation we
got ourselves five new tv spots for the
batman that supposedly include plenty of
new footage take a batarang to that like
button people can't wait for this movie
comes out in like a month oh my god it's
so soon it's almost here i can't believe it
can't believe we've been hearing a lot of
things about this film and perhaps we'll
touch on some details that the cast has
recently been talking about as well let's just
swing into action and see what we got today
fear is a tool they think i'm hiding in
the shadows watching waiting to strike
but i am the shadows oh man he
delivers those lines so well
i am the shadows
the batman he's trailers
why is he writing to you
it's all about the wings you'd
be surprised but even a good man
is kick carbide hey whoa it had
like pov shot my whole life wow
maybe this is all coming to an end
the batman there's a lot of new stuff in that yeah
got this about a king compressors to
match maybe this is all coming to an end
god damn right yeah you are that shot love
the way they're doing all this aerial stuff
scared me with that mask in that cave
it's nice to actually get some carbide
before you've nothing left i
don't care what happens to me
what are we looking for i'm vengeance
come on vengeance let's get into some trouble
i've always
loved the music in all these
spots man yeah all these drops bro
he's involved in this oh he's not
involved how do you know stop it delany
what are you hiding
oh wow wow looks like those were great those
were like really solid short trailers today
i really hope every scene with the penguin
involves him getting beat up by batman's car
i'm just genuinely loving how haunting and
menacing batman himself is feeling you know
it's so interesting hearing what some of the early
reactions have been for the movie as well as what
the cast especially with robert pattinson has
been talking about lately saying how this is
like an unusual film that it's not what you're
probably expecting and that it's a little bit more
sad than what you'd be expecting too especially
watching these five spots back to back the feeling
doesn't ignite in me of the hero batman what i
get in here is the threat the menacing threat that
lurks in the shadows as he says in the trailer he
is the shadows remember in like bvs the first time
you see the the criminals that uh when the cops
are going in there and that afflicts batman's
kind of at the the top corner of the ceiling
that right there of like this is the thing that
the criminals fear that's what this feels like but
the entire time the handy circus was saying robert
pattinson does such a great job at this like
almost jekyll and hyde thing with the character
he's two completely different people when he's
bruce wayne versus batman and they keep showing
this one moment of maybe it's just a good trailer
line but they keep showing this one moment robert
pattinson saying you lied to me alfred and from
what andy serkis was revealing himself was that
their relationship starts off really strained
where alfred struggles to be the father figure
that he strives for to be in bruce's life but you
know bruce just keeps pulling away from him and is
going down this path which is very you know bruce
to do and i've been hearing like it's it's complex
and that's going to be making some choices that
will probably challenge the audience so good one
last thing i was expecting was you know something
that could potentially border on divisive i wasn't
that's the last thing i was anticipating but it
sounds like this is going to be something that
is not the fun superhero movie at all yeah while
there's going to be a lot of badassery to it that
it's really going to be quite introspective on
all the characters like every character here
especially from what colin farrell was talking
about with zoe kravitz has been saying what what
paul dana was talking about too like paul dana was
saying that for the riddler it was more than just
pulling from comics it was about embodying
what gotham is like really feeling what the
city of gotham is and being reflective of that
he does have a political agenda watching how this
is all gonna unfold like this this just seems
like brutal and unsettling like it's just gonna
get under your skin i don't know i mean to me
that just sounds like a perfect pep in movies
it does well and it sounds something akin to and
not to say that any of the previous or that many
of the previous batman movies haven't felt like
this but yeah it feels very akin to some of those
broader more expansive graphic novels that you get
to yeah spend a lot of time in with the characters
but also with the action yeah like the way that
they're drawing just the overall vibe of gotham it
feels like an affliction that everyone has to live
with yeah everyone is struggling against no matter
whether it's the street punks or the politicians
or bruce himself i love the way that even in these
trailers you get that duality of it looks
completely badass and completely brutal and
completely dark in a cool way but also really
emotionally heavy and warped and anguished and
strained and strange and yeah i love the idea
that you have what appears to be a really gripping
action thriller but also a really harsh emotional
drama and i get that vibe increasingly with every
trailer even though the trailers are really uh
focal about you know the physical aspects the
action the different colorful characters showing
up but yeah even getting more of carmine falcone
here like i i like that they're slowly creeping
in more of that political gender agenda and
the political sort of stratosphere that gotham
exists within and if you guys don't know what
carmine falcone is he's uh he's basically like
modbus yeah he runs a lot of continents you know
you've got all that fun stuff oh how are all the
different characters going to interact but what's
most exciting is that you know sort of personal i
want to know what personal conversation batman and
the ruler are going to have what does the riddler
know about bruce wayne what does he know about his
family and i imagine there's going to be a lot of
incredible eye acting yes because as much as we
want like the white eyes considering just how much
the promotions for this film keep him primarily in
the suit it makes me think that he'll be in the
suit for like most of this movie versus him being
bruce wayne predominantly and then some of
the time he's batman primarily relying on body
language and just his eyes and if anyone can bring
so much depth and pain and anguish to the eyes
it's gonna be robert pattinson he's a phenomenal
actor and you know what dude i gotta point out
the way they're utilizing even the freaking
batmobile even his car like what i love is
how everything feels and rob hasn't talked about
this too like you could feel the seams within his
suit you can tell like everything is just like a
little bit more beaten down and it's all rugged
diy yeah good way to put it even with the with
the batmobile which i think the prequel novel
unveiled that he built that at like 16 years old
or at least building cars at 16 or something like
that with that batmobile that shot that you have
in there of it appearing and the penguins staring
it down like even giving the batmobile a real
presence that oh my god look out for that car it's
also a character yeah it's awesome it's so cool i
don't know i mean if it is a little bit divisive
if it is like it makes some choices that challenge
audiences i'm all for it man i mean we've had like
a gazillion batman interpretations by this
point bring on something that challenges the
audience a little bit more why not guys leave your
thoughts down below what you think about all this
footage you can subscribe click that bell hit that
like button and hey we will catch you guys soon